كانت شوارع المدينة الصاخبة ذات يوم جالسة مهجورة محادثة بين الأجيال وأجبرت على الابتعاد عن متاجر البقالة مرتديًا ملابس مؤقتة من الواضح أن عامل الرعاية الصحية مرهق في الخطوط الأمامية.هذه بعض الصور التي تلتقط وقتًا محوريًا في التاريخ كمتاحف ومؤسسات ثقافية حولها يعمل العالم على توثيق جائحة فيروس كورونا ، من المهم حقًا بالنسبة للأجيال القادمة أن يكونوا قادرين على النظر إلى الوراء ورؤية ما يجب أن يحدث حتى نكون جميعًا آمنين ، وأعتقد أيضًا أنها طريقة مفيدة لمعالجة بعض المشاعر والإحباطات الصعبة حقًا التي نمر بها جميعًا في أواخر أبريل ، طلبت إنجلترا التاريخية من الناس الحصول على صور للحياة أثناء الإغلاق في دعوتهم الأولى لتقديم الطلبات العامة منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية في أسبوع واحد ، حيث تلقوا ما يقرب من 3000 مشاركة من جميع أنحاء البلاد لتوضيح تجربة جماعية متنوعة لقد رأينا الكثير من أقواس قزح التي أصبحت رمزًا حقيقيًا في المملكة المتحدة لنوع من التضامن
لقد رأينا خلال هذا الوقت الكثير من
الأمثلة لأشخاص يخرجون للتصفيق لمقدمي الرعاية ،
لدينا بعض الصور الجميلة حقًا
لأشخاص يتواصلون مع أقاربهم المسنين
، ومن دواعي سرورنا حقًا أننا
رأينا مثالًا حقيقيًا لهذا النوع من
البريطانيين  حس الفكاهة أعاد أحد الزوجين
إنشاء فراش جون لينون ويوكو أونو ،
لكنه بقي رسائل في المنزل
وراءه ، لذا من الجيد حقًا أن نرى
أنه حتى في مواجهة هذه المحنة
، لا يزال الناس يحافظون على روح
الدعابة في
أماكن أخرى.
عرض لكن الأشياء المادية
المميزة لوقت غير مسبوق ،
بالتأكيد الشيء المتكرر هو
أقنعة الوجه ، فقد أصبحت أقوى
رمز مرئي للأزمة ، كما أنها
أصبحت بيانًا سياسيًا أيضًا
سواء قررت ارتداء واحدة أم لا
تفكر في ما تشعر به
جهود الحكومة لإعادة الفتح
والفئة الأخرى المتنامية هي
الأشياء التي تصنعها الشركات التي
ركزت إنتاجها من
أجل خدمة الاحتياجات المستمرة  فيما يتعلق بالأزمة ، أطلقت الجمعية التاريخية في نيويورك مجموعتها الخاصة بفيروس كورونا في آذار (مارس) بدءًا بزجاجة واحدة من مطهر اليد ، وكان تركيزهم هو المصنوعات المادية للأدلة الوبائية التي تحدد وقتًا مؤلمًا قد يصبح مفيدًا في المستقبل ، حسنًا ، سنعود إلى الأنفلونزا جائحة عام 1918 أربعة دروس مستفادة من تلك التجربة وننظر في تدابير الصحة العامة التي تم اتخاذها والتدخلات الحكومية التي تم اتخاذها أو عدم اتخاذها للإرشاد بشأن ما قد يكون الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب فعله الآن لافتات تقدم القفازات لأولئك الذين يستطيعون ' نوفر لها ملعبًا مطوقًا لمنع الأطفال من جمع شاشات الكمبيوتر المستخدمة للتواصل الاجتماعي في عصر التباعد الاجتماعي ، هذه هي العناصر والصور التي ستروي قصة وقتنا غير المسبوق لتشكيل كيف يتذكر العالم جائحة فيروس كورونا سارة فانير سي إن إن أنت